[Music]
hi welcome et live I'm Sophia lacy here
with Jesse McCartney Sophie how are you
good how are you well Jesse has a new
single out right now called better with
you congratulations thank you so much
it's so awesome I'm so excited to have
you back on the music see you me too I'm
happy to be back tell us a little bit
about how this song and this project
came together yeah so you know I had
taken a sort of a long period of time
off almost four years and I had been
doing a lot of traveling a lot of dining
learning how to cook just kind of
exploring new creative avenues and
trying to find myself I guess in a sense
and and it wasn't until I don't know
about a year ago one of my buddies hit
me up and or a couple years ago and
invited me to this songwriting camp for
country music it was like a country pop
songwriting camp and he was inviting
people from all around the country to
sort of fly to Nashville and write just
write every day for three weeks and it
sounded interesting because I had never
really tried my hand at country and knew
nothing about country music and so I
want to give it a go and I flew down
there and it was one of the most
enlightening fun experiences of my
career I got to write with amazing
songwriters learned so much about
songwriting in general and that was sort
of I think the bug that bit me again and
I came back to LA and I was like okay
you know what I think I need to to work
on my own stuff I'd been in the studio
it sort of sharpened my writing tools
and from that point on I went in the
studio and one of the very first songs
that I had written was better with you
and so that kind of became the beginning
of where we are now that's awesome and I
have to say I had no idea you were gonna
say that about Nashville and yeah music
I am a country girl myself I love
country music and pop music so I'd love
to talk to you a little bit more about
that about you were writing with and
kind of that whole experience in the
country world yeah so Shane Stevens is a
songwriter who I've worked with I've
worked with out my last project and he's
a guy who's well known and prolific
writer in the country scene and he
basically put us in a room with it was
starstruck it was like Reba McEntire
studio and so we were in with just a
bunch of songwriters that you know
I could list them but I don't know if
everyone is gonna know who they are but
there I was in a room with like three or
four different writers every day and the
idea was you'd write one song a day and
it was sort of an exercise and just
writing you know and being quick and
trying to finish something cuz it'll
often times you'll write a song and
it'll never get finished and like three
four days will go by and yeah let's
start something new the idea was to no
matter what finished the song so a lot
of them were awful right but some of
them were pretty good and yeah and I got
to you know I got to write country which
was something I'd never done before and
they're very similar it's very similar
to pop but just with like twang twang
vocals and you know could we see you
crossing over into that realm I don't
think any time soon but it was
definitely I mean it was just a fun
experience and I got to open my whole
you know a whole new world for me and
let's talk about this song better with
you specifically first of all I want to
show a little bit of the video here
you've got Danielle Campbell in there
with you how much fun did you guys have
yeah Danielle is great she's a fine
actress and just was super lovely to
work with and I knew I wanted somebody
who had a comfortability behind the
camera you know oftentimes when you
shoot a video you get somebody who just
hasn't been on set before and this was
such a personal you know video
displaying a long relationship and I had
to have somebody who's gonna be
absolutely comfortable on set from the
jump and she just did an incredible job
and a big shout-out to my debt director
Joe Roy who executed it perfectly she
and I sat down and hashed this this idea
out for many many many weeks but months
even before we were able to land on this
sort of concept but yeah I'm really
excited about the video and I mean you
got to get comfortable pretty quick to
be that in that close proximity yeah
yeah I mean it's definitely it's one of
those things I think after a while is
part of the business like you just kind
of kind of you're you accept that that's
you know one of the things that you have
to do but yeah I mean I mean how do you
jump right into that like was it like
hey I'm Jesse nice to meet you sort of I
mean I mean sort of it's a you know one
of the things that I think just comes
with the territory you know and I have
to say like you know song
that is so personal too it's like it's I
mean you have to you have to have a
visual that matches it so you have to
look boner Bowl and comfortable and just
kind of part of the territory I guess
can you tell me a little bit about the
inspiration for the song yeah so it was
you know about a year ago that I walked
into the studio and one of my buddies
Brandon Burnett who's a co-writer of the
song came in and he's like hey I have
this verse idea what do you think of
this and it was the beginning of the the
song which is I know it's ugly turning
on the news and during that time it was
just a super contentious feeling like
they'd wake up and there's just feeling
of angst in the air it was a very
complicated time a lot of division among
everyone in the country it was a crazy
election going on and it in many ways is
still kind of happening where you turn
on the news and it's like there's always
a lot going on and I don't know I just I
felt awful you know I think everybody
that I was working with at that time
I've been working with Brandon for
several months and we all kind of felt
like this odd Judah you know and I think
we just wanted to feel better and so
this song was a way to just kind of make
us feel better and I think in many ways
now has connected with with everybody
you know and the song is about meeting
somebody who is just amazing who you
know brings out the best version of you
and is there for all the terrible times
for all the really great times and you
know in many ways that's a partner a
significant other some ways that's like
a dog or like your parent but I think
anybody
everyone can sort of relate to finding
somebody that is just the best match you
know absolutely I want to get to some
fan questions here I said I'm coming in
thank you so much guys keep them coming
we'll ask as many as we can Amanda from
YouTube wants to know if you could do it
with anyone dead or alive who would it
be and why hey Amanda what's going on um
that's a good question they're probably
too many to count
but I think I think probably it would be
the first person I ever remember
listening to as a kid which was Elvis
Presley I was like four and a half years
old and I pulled the
one of his albums out of my parents
record collection and I just remember
thinking he was the coolest in the world
and so in many ways I like discovered
him on my own and so I don't know it
just would be really cool to do blue
suede shoes with Elvis Presley you can't
beat Elvis no way
Leslie from YouTube wants to know what's
the craziest fan encounter you've ever
had craziest fanning you have to have a
lot you've had a lot of had some good
ones yeah I've had some good ones I tell
this story because it's really it's a
good one but hey Leslie I so I was in
Chicago this is the very beginning of my
career in 2000 like four or five and I
just come onto the scene beautiful soul
had just come out I was on a television
show a hit show on The WB called
Summerland and it was like a crazy time
for me and I remember getting called to
do a meet-and-greet at one of these
malls in Chicago and they expected like
anywhere between 3 and 400 people and I
got there and there had been over 8,000
people that had showed up for this event
and they did not have the security for
this type of event it was a bunch of
like just older geriatric dudes with
security badges that just had no
business you know getting me through the
crowd onto the stage and essentially
what happened was I was in the center
and there was like you know a circle of
security detail around me and we're like
cruising through the audience because
that was the only way we could get to
the stage was to go through 8,000 people
and just as soon as we started one by
one each security guard just started
going down like the girls were just like
knocking them down and all of a sudden
it's me on my own just running for my
life trying to get to the stage and I
remember this one girl came in as well
womp and she grabbed my hair anyway
whack and I just remember thinking like
oh my gosh something's and I look over
and she has like a fistful of my hair
pulled it out and I looked at her and
she looked at me and she was like I'm
like shaking and I'm shaking with
adrenaline I'm like is that my hair and
then I get to the stage and I'm like oh
my god that was my hair I'm bleeding
hyah and like I only go to sing and I'm
like crying and cuz the pain and like
bleeding but also so excited that this
many people showed up that was probably
the craziest fan moment I can I can ever
remember that's pretty insane dancing I
mean how do you handle that though
because obviously you love your fans and
you know you want to have this
connection with them but at the same
time like pulling out hair is not cool
guys yes please don't I'm it hurts no
it's I don't know I mean it's in in some
ways like it's you know it's one of
those moments that you kind of dream of
where it's like this sort of you know
Elvis Presley situation I know and so
for me it was it was bittersweet
I now need you know hair plugs in that
one am i Hannah from facebook says do
you ever get told you look like a young
Leonardo DiCaprio hey Hannah I do get
that from time to time I think yeah I
don't know maybe some somewhere back in
our lineage maybe we are like long
distant cousins or something but it's a
compliment he's obviously won Basketball
Diaries it was like one of the reasons I
wanted to start acting and performing so
that's a big compliment of course I
didn't see it before but I do actually
now that she says it
so you mentioned Summerland a minute ago
and I actually have been wanting to ask
you about this because we had Lori
Loughlin in our studio and she said she
was open to doing a summer line reunion
actually did she yeah she did say that
she saw you at the Super Bowl recently
yeah what did you guys talk about we you
know we ran into each other I was
walking I can't was coming out of my out
of the booth I was there for an amazing
charity called love your melon and they
invited myself and my girlfriend down
and we were hanging out in the booth and
we're watching the game and I ran out
and I literally ran into her like I
almost stepped on her and I was like oh
my gosh hey and she's like hey and we
just caught up and she you know she
asked me how I was doing how my mom was
she was asked about my family and you
know we talked about her girls who were
now like all grown up I remember her
daughter Ava I think it is was on set
like back on Summerlin days she was like
four years old and now she looks just
like Lori anyway yeah this is throwback
picture for a second here yeah oh yeah
he looks exactly exactly the same she is
beautiful as ever
and yeah and we just kind of caught up
and you know Lori is like a there's
something she just has like this older
sister or motherly vibed where she
always like took care of me on set I
just moved to LA from New York and she
was just uh she was a great role model
great you know somebody did good to know
in Hollywood I got to tell you that we
also talked to zac efron recently about
Summerland and he said that he had such
a crush on Laurie she looked like
something out of Sports Illustrated to
him everybody has a crime where is the
most lovable person in in Hollywood you
can't you know I've never met anybody
who doesn't absolutely fall in love with
Laurie Lachlan did you have a crush on
her back then of course everybody did
everybody on set did everyone what do
you be open to doing a reunion
totally I'd be down what kind of story
do you think there would be the Telex
that was I think Laurie's only
hesitation about it was she didn't know
what the story would be it is a good
point I'd have to think about it I'm
sure you know the meeting of the minds
we could come up with something great
there's help you guys will hang onto
hope right there um some more questions
coming in Carrie from Facebook I'm going
back to the music for a second she says
how do you think your musical evolution
from beautiful soul to better with you
has shaped you as an artist hey Carrie I
think actually many ways it feels sort
of like a cyclical thing it's sort of
come back I feel like in many ways
better with you is very reminiscent
sonically of a beautiful soul it sounds
I think it's why it's it's tickling
maybe like a nostalgic bone for a lot of
people because it sounds like a simpler
time this new song it sounds like just a
free carefree three-and-a-half minutes
of just like escape and I think that's
what beautiful soul did back in two
thousand four and five and you know from
you know since that time I you know I've
explored different musical avenues and
I've walked down the arm B path and done
more rhythmic stuff and it's nice to do
kind of an organic pop song again and I
think it it sort of brings me back to my
roots can we expect a full-length album
this year are you working on that I
don't know yet so right now as of now
I'm doing a sort of a song by song basis
and I have a collection of about five
songs that I love that I'm going to
release but yeah for right now I just
want to spend all of my time on each
song and give all of my attention to one
song at a time and and follow that with
a tour at some point this summer but but
ya know you're gonna get a lot of music
this year whether or not it's a full LP
I don't know but but I will keep you
posted any thoughts on who you might
want to tour with that's a good question
I haven't really thought about that
either I think you know right out of the
gate I'd love to do my own tour and just
kind of reestablish my relationship with
all the fans and re-engage with them and
do it's been a while since I've been out
there and do I have done a full-length
tour so I kind of want to get back into
the to the rehearsal studio with my band
and come up with a new exciting fresh
setlist and just kind of do my own thing
for for a little bit and if something
else comes along when there's like a
great partnership or matchup I can work
something out with another artist and
you know I'll never close that door but
I think in the beginning I'd love to
kind of head out by myself you mentioned
the nostalgia bit a little bit it makes
me curious do you enjoy playing kind of
some of the stuff from back in the day
or do you hate it a little bit of course
yeah you know there's nothing you can't
ever I don't know how to explain what it
feels like when somebody else is singing
your music and and especially in like a
crowd of people you know an entire crowd
of people is in unison singing your song
it's it never gets old and I mean you
know it the exciting thing about being
an artist is that you get to perform new
music but at the same time you have to
respect the fact that the reason you're
there is because of the old music so you
need to you need to be able to balance
your setlist with like the old stuff the
oldies and goodies but but like the new
stuff as well to keep it fresh for
myself but you know the reason they're
there is because you know it brings you
know one of those songs brings them back
to a point in their life or you were
their guy so you gotta you gotta balance
it Emily yes Emily from YouTube wants to
know if you found it difficult to grow
up in the spotlight at times I think
that you know there were definitely
times where it was complicated you know
I think when you're a young teenager or
you know a prepubescent male it's very
you know
a lot of things happen that don't you
don't always want to happen publicly and
they do and you know it's it
can be hard to to sort of deal with
everyone's reactions to that and also
there's a lot of sacrifices that you
have to make you know I missed a lot of
school dances I missed a lot of family
time and family trips and you know I
it's just one of those things that I'll
you know I won't ever get back but at
the same time what I got in return was
something incredibly special that every
a lot of people dream about and you
can't have you can't have all of this
without giving up something else you
know and it's still still something I
deal with you know and and promoting a
new record even like you miss holidays
you miss birthdays you miss things that
you want to be there for but you know
it's something has to give so you know
it's kind of one of those things but I I
managed to get through and I think with
having a really great team around you
people who will tell you know until you
look you can't do this cuz you're gonna
like no one will like you if you do that
you have to have people around you to
tell you that and I think if you can
surround yourself with good people you
know you can you can get through all the
the trials and tribulations of being a
teenager in the public eye sure now
you've also done a lot of acting over
the years music and acting so is there
any acting projects that you're working
on right now not right now I think you
know right now this year is totally
entirely dedicated to music and getting
back on the road and being in front of
the fans I did take some time you know
during that little four year gap I did a
little bit of work on fear the walking
dead I saw that yeah dislike villainous
pirate who gets on board and like holds
people hostage
that's a cool gun-toting yeah it was
super fun and a couple of like crime
dramas and stuff just to kind of fill
the time and and be creative but I right
now it's it's all about music and no
immediate plans for any acting stuff
okay I do got to ask I saw this question
from Ashley on Facebook you voiced
Nightwing aka Robin and they're
currently casting a live-action version
she wants to know who you would like to
see cast or if you would want to do it
Ashley yeah I'd love to do it because I
know Nightwing and Robin probably better
than anybody right now I don't know I
yeah I mean they should they should just
cast you know I should be their guy they
should just guess
- right easy done another question about
the music
Shanice I'm really sorry if I'm not
pronouncing that right from Facebook how
would you describe the sound or vibe of
your upcoming project it's either
Shanice Arshin ice
there's only two ways I'm guessing
Shanice is probably it's probably right
what do you guys how would you describe
the sound or vibe of your upcoming
project so it's it's like I said it's
earlier it's got this very sort of pop
feel to it it's a little less rhythmic
than maybe my last project it's still so
full band but there's a lot of organic
elements and you know like guitars and
piano but it's it's got more of a pop
just a pop feel and a feel-good vibe I
think it's some of the subject matter -
lyrically is this kind of drives with
today and what's happening there are
some topical songs that are you know
discussing serious things and overall I
think you get this it just it makes me
feel good I think you know that was just
kind of what I wanted to do with this
project is at this point in time it just
feels like everyone is a little uneasy
and I just wanted to like have a place
for people to escape for a little bit
you know with with music so yeah I love
that putting you on the spot here is
Tori from Facebook asking the hard
questions I like it Tori she says how
are you and your girlfriend will we see
a proposal soon probably watching this
right now that she is I know so if you
were hoping to keep it a surprise
so she's the best we've been together
five years and I you know we'll keep you
posted
how'd you know she was is she the one
she honestly is she's the most
incredible girl I've ever ever been with
she's super loyal and compassionate and
you know deals with know she knows she
knows how to gauge my personality better
than anybody I've ever met she knows
exactly what to say at the right time
she's also an incredible chef he's an
incredible comedian she's hilarious
he's done a lot of riding together she's
um she's really a great match happy for
you thank you awesome
deidre says she saw you on tour with
Pauly D in the Backstreet Boys yeah
was that Pauly D which band or artist is
your guilty pleasure my guilty pleasure
band er artists do you love the
throwback says I feel like 90s and early
2000s nostalgia is like it right now you
know what I really loved about the 90s
and like well everyone was listening to
like Metallica and Nine Inch Nails and
like heavy metal rock I seriously was
listening to like babyface and even the
Hansen brothers I love their like super
talented musicians they don't get credit
like who else
I just loved pop music you know I was
like TLC like I listened to TLC like
right now I've been where I've been
rocking the crazysexycool album like
almost every day at my car all my
favorite records alright and one last
one pancakes and tea from YouTube I like
the name what is the story behind having
a photo of Katy Perry in your music
video oh so you know what I think that
was because let me just think about that
for a second because I think she did she
do something in her one of her videos I
can't remember she did something or you
know what it was we had just we had just
like come off of like a radio promo
thing uh-huh
and we had like run into each other all
the time oh I know what it was she had
just done a video on her she had just
shot a video in her hotel room of
singing leavin and she won like
something with her girlfriend and she
was doing that she was singing like g5g
[ __ ] and she had done something that sort
of went online and became like a little
viral moment and it was like the week
before a couple weeks before I was
shooting my how do you sleep video so it
was a way for me to sort of respond to
that yeah I put a little photo in my if
you look a lot of people don't know that
actually it's a little anecdotal thing
about the video that's fun but yeah
there's a there's a picture it's like a
little I don't know it means like a
wallet-sized photo nobody even has those
anymore
on your - on my visor and you pull down
it's Katy Perry and she acknowledged it
later she's like thanks for doing else
you know yeah a little back and forth
which was it was fun that's really fun I
love those kind of interactions is there
anybody that you've been like really
starstruck by over the years
Stevie Wonder was a big one for me I ran
into him I performed that this this sort
of pre-grammy party that was celebrating
the career of Stevie Wonder and I sang
one of his songs and you know again he
was one of the artists that I grew up
listening to when I was a kid and pulled
his album out of my parents collection
and just fell in love with his voice and
his you know all of the runs that he was
capable of doing and from the time that
I was a kid I tried to emulate that and
he shaped my me vocally in many ways and
anyway I had the opportunity years ago
to sing while he was in the front row
and he was doing like the Stevie thing
like jamming out and it was just like
one of those surreal moments and then
afterwards he came backstage and he was
like thanks so much for singing you're
my song man and he was just the nicest
most gracious man and I just remember
thinking like well never I'll never
forget that moment you know it's so good
when somebody you love that much just
lives up to it they're actually nice and
they're so like totally generous yeah
that's amazing man I know you too and
with that you guys it is about time for
us to say goodbye thank you Jesse so
much yeah yeah it was awesome check out
his new music online right now better
with you you can see the video on
YouTube and where else can they find
your music right now yeah just go check
out the video on on Bebo YouTube and go
check out better with you on on spot of
wherever you get your music you can find
better with you so and then when do you
think you'll have more coming for us
in the next few months okay well hold
you to that Thank You Jesse thank you so
much thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you